there are some pretty notable people uh
who are being hit in this Epstein list
uh Bill Clinton is the main one here is
a picture of Bill Clinton this is not a
new picture this is a picture of Bill
Clinton and Jeffrey Epstein from this is
probably about 30 or so years ago uh and
here is an image this is a picture of a
painting that was hanging in Jeffrey
Epstein's townhouse in New York City
that's Bill Clinton obviously in a Blue
Dress which is a reference to Monica
Lewinsky uh and he's pointing like
there's just something kind of fishy and
weird about this okay so be it uh here's
video this is uh this is what about two
three weeks ago Bill Clinton being asked
about his friendship with Jeffrey
Epstein it's a little hard to hear the
audio here but hopefully you'll get
it any comments on the alleg allegation
prodction with
[Music]
Jeffrey hey my
gu all right he kind of does what they
all do like he laughs it off and then he
says say I think the evidence is it's
unclear what he says I think the
evidence is clear I think the evidence
is unclear I don't know exactly but when
it comes to evidence so yesterday this
list was released and Bill Clinton was
in it take a look this is from the
deposition that they released question
let me back up do you know if Bill
Clinton was a friend of Jeffrey Epstein
answer I knew he had dealings with Bill
Clinton I did not know they were friends
until I read the Vanity Fair article
about them going to Africa together
question did Jeffrey ever talk to you
about Bill Clinton answer he said one
time that Clinton likes them young
referring to girls now I believe the
person being questioned in that is one
of at the time one of the underaged
girls who knows if she's telling the
truth or anything else but this is now
evidence right like when people are
testifying under oath this is evidence
so Bill Clinton was asking for evidence
to be released well it's a type of
evidence right there uh there is a
little bit more it gets weirder uh this
is an email from Jeffrey Epstein to
Jazelle Maxwell who is now the only
person in prison related to any of these
files so this is Epstein to Maxwell you
can issue a reward to any of Virginia's
friends acquaintances now Virginia is
one of the underage girls uh Virginia's
friends acquaintances family that come
forward and help prove her allegations
are false the strongest is the Clinton
dinner and the new version in the Virgin
Island
uh that stepen Hawking participated in
an underage
orgy what are we doing with our lives
what are we
doing